[Music]
hi everyone thanks for joining us today
for the developer live q a i'm aja
and a reminder that this q a is live if
you want to join the conversation reach
out on twitter with the hashtag google
cloud next
we've reached out asking for your
questions on social media and y'all have
been responding
we'll be answering your questions during
the next 20 minutes
and first of all let's welcome priyanka
who's here to answer your questions with
me today hi priyanka
thanks aja that keynote was absolutely
amazing yeah so let's get into the
goodness that earth and aparna shared a
highlight for me was really that
upcoming documentary on kubernetes so
cool
i also enjoyed um the google cloud
innovator community announcement
securing software supply chain and
building sustainably uh what caught your
eye a lot of the stuff you just
mentioned um definitely our innovations
in sustainability the ability to see
your carbon footprint of your cloud
workloads is really really cool when i
heard about in yesterday's keynote i
immediately went and looked at all my
personal projects to see the carbon cost
of what i'd been doing and i love having
that kind of data to use in decision
making like
help me make the right decisions
but i'm mostly really excited about the
cloud innovators program i've really
missed interacting with our google cloud
dev community i want to hear and see all
the amazing things the community's been
up to and the innovators program should
let us do that and we're working on some
super special innovators only events in
2022 that i can't wait to tell the
community about wow yeah that all sounds
really amazing i'm also excited about
that secure supply chain announcement
salsa
and how the combination of cloud build
and binary authorization actually helps
kick-start your journey to secure your
software artifacts by fully automating
that build process
yeah that's just
so interesting that's so cool
so let's get to our first question we've
got the questions coming in uh just for
the folks at home the backstage crew is
looking for your tweets as well so keep
them coming in during thing we'll be
bringing them in live
so our first question is from asher and
it is who would be good candidates for
the pursuit
participation in the private preview of
earth engine yeah so um anybody who is
like doing work on sustainable
things right so with the sustainability
lens if you're thinking about financial
services um the customer packaged goods
and their impact on the environment and
how all of that can be combined together
so
yeah anything that that you're doing
with the sustainability lens obviously
it's in private preview so you have to
uh you you have to qualify and stuff but
but if you have that angle of
sustainability you're probably a right
fit for it awesome thank you for that
ah second question came in from
priyanka's twitter and i saw this one
this morning as i was coming in to do
this q a
and this one is any examples do we have
any examples of end-to-end spark-based
pipelines for ml
they'd love to see them specifically
they're interested in learning how
serverless spark can be leveraged in big
data and ml ops framework on google
cloud
yeah so um uh thank you for this
question i think it came from parent i
saw my twitter this morning
so uh really what it's all about is the
serverless spark ml framework is is
about you not having to create your
backend infrastructure
to run spark so that's all taken care of
for you so you can just run your
workloads which is in this case like
you're you're trying to run a machine
learning spark job you can just get
started by not worrying about the
infrastructure so that's one part the
other piece of it is the ml the vortex
workbench um which is the
jupiter notebook but but hosted uh but
it also gives you the opportunity to
connect with dataproc or the spark ml
jobs that you might have built um and
and all run all of that so as a data
scientist i can just use my workbench
and that becomes my home to kind of get
the data massage it connect with data
procs spark ml jobs and then and then
get all those uh predictions right in
that one spot
awesome thanks priyanka that was a
really comprehensive answer
ah so now we have a question from
christopher and it's what are the
benefits of the innovators program you
mind if i take this one yeah please
so the big benefit of the innovators
program is going to be access to
innovators only events like we're going
to be doing some amas we're planning
right now road map meetings potentially
and there's also an innovator's virtual
background that you can download and use
in your google meet
meetings uh another question came in
from twitter
awesome
so let me read this one my pov massive
focus on the security massive focus on
the security focus in the developer
cloud isn't this a topic that matters
more for the managers of developers than
for developers and i'll take this one
too if that's cool with you yeah so i'm
a manager and yeah that's a really good
question security is vital to all
aspects of software development and
security needs to be everyone's job yeah
managers need to care a lot about it but
we need to make the tools so that
developers can do the right thing
automatically and that everyone is
participating in making our cloud more
secure
and we talked about some of those things
we talked about
our tooling that can help you make sure
that you put your secrets in secure
locations as opposed to putting them in
code we talked about the salsa we've
talked about lots of other parts and all
of this is part of a secure software
supply chain but security does need to
be everyone's job
managers can help by teaching their
developers and enforcing it but everyone
needs to take the steps to make things
more secure
so yes good point but everyone's
involved
okay this is a great one from priyanka's
linkedin
is it possible to connect to the public
ip of a cloud sql instance from a
private cloud run service who i've been
asked this one before when visiting
customers yeah also is this a cr is this
cross project setup
cloud run service and cloud sql instance
are on separate gcp projects so can you
do a cross project setup with your
database and you're running a service
somewhere else priyanka you you actually
can so you have in this scenario you
have a cloud sql instance in one project
and you have um your you have your
compute or whatever is calling that
cloud sql instance in another project
and you could totally make them work by
using um what is called as private
private service access what it does is
it connects the two together even with a
private ip so you don't even have to
expose a public ip for your for your
cloud sql instance which is again comes
back to the security point you were
making earlier everybody has to think
about security so you're not exposing
with public ip you're just using the
private ip of your cloud sql instance
and connecting it to the virtual machine
or
wherever you're running your compute to
call your servers from so it's possible
private service access is the service
you're looking for to kind of connect
the two together it's a vpc offering
awesome thank you so much bianca
cool a question from andy oh this is one
of my favorites so there's a lot of ways
to run an application on google cloud
it's a huge platform
how do i know what to what i should
choose where do i run my stuff should i
run it on gke compute engine cloud run
so many good choices
yeah this is this is a question we get a
lot right and it's um it really just
depends on your situation and the
situations can be a lot the type of team
the size of team um and the number of
number of developers you have and and
the and the languages that you might be
using so um there are lots of different
scenarios in which you can decide so
i'll give an example of a few so for
example compute engine like if you're
migrating and you just want to get from
on-premise infrastructure into cloud and
you just want the speed you just want to
get there
i would choose compute engine to just
migrate as is and then modernize later
if needed sometimes you don't need to
modernize if you have licensing
requirements and stuff like that um so
that's compute engine the um if you want
to work with containers need a little
bit more abstraction less abstraction
you can work with containers with gke
and that gives you a lot more control
over the number of nodes you have and
and the processing that you're using um
but if you might be just wanting to run
containers but don't want to manage the
underlying infrastructure like nodes and
and stuff like that and the regions just
use cloud run because it's serverless
but it allows you to
use your container
container images and just deploy them
cloud functions is kind of like
everywhere so you're trying to do we
handle one function
or a piece of
a piece or a feature of code that you
just
just deploy in a function um as a as a
function as a code sort of service uh
but it kind of applies everywhere so i
wouldn't say uh so cloud function is not
like a or a it's more of a and like it
works with with any of those it's just
more of an extension and enhancement of
your services with serverless so i hope
that that helped clarify a little bit of
that but there's a lot that goes in that
decision yeah i know and i really liked
how you called out that cloud functions
is not an or it's an and it's cloud
functions is just fantastic at tying
pieces together it's one of the things i
love about it
and i'm just going to point out for
folks that we have sessions on all of
these in the breakouts so if you want to
go learn more about these go look in our
breakouts and you can find out more
about the different offerings that
google cloud has
so now we have a question from esther
what language is the cloud run and cloud
function support oh let's see if i can
do this from memory i've been practicing
so gcf these are the standard languages
you see on google cloud we've got
node.js python go
java.net
ruby and php i got them all awesome
cloud run supports any language or any
library or any binaries that you can put
in a container but if you want to use
the source code deploys feature that
abby showed earlier
that is supported on
node python go java and net and specific
versions of those languages are
supported so please do go to the website
and make sure the version that you need
is the one that we support
great memory by the way oh yeah i've
been getting really good at naming all
those languages
so from selena
oh yes great question when should i use
gke autopilot versus cloud run
um i'll let you take that let me take
this one okay
so this
pretty much boils down to do you want
kubernetes or not
if you want kubernetes if you want the
enhanced flexibility that kubernetes has
you want to have all those knobs and
dials that you can turn to really fine
tune everything for your networking
needs or your particular load profile
use gke autopilot
if you want to can if you have a
container and you want to run it on gcp
and that's your goal cloud runs great
cloud runs fantastic at that
and as we pointed out you don't even
need a container if you use cloud cloud
run source deploys for those languages i
just mentioned
more questions
oh this one's for you priyanka this is
from caleb
what file formats are supported with the
doc ai stuff that any talked about oh
yeah so um you can do images and pdfs
it's really about the unstructured um
image data so pdfs and images
awesome
okay
let's see what else we got
oh this one's from mark another one for
you priyanka oh it's another security
question
so can you tell us more about binary
authorization we covered it very briefly
in the keynote but it's something i've
been hearing a lot about and i'd love to
know a little more about it yes again it
kind of boils down to the whole like
security narrative that that you
mentioned that everybody's kind of
responsible for um for the security of
um the entire platform so in this case
um but with binary authors really deploy
time security so you're deploying um and
making sure that your images or
container images if you're using
gke or cloud run
works with binary auth so when you're at
your deployment stage uh you have uh you
you can provide signature authorizations
on your images um so if and and the um
and the verification and the authorities
for those so if they are if they are
authorized only binary author will apply
the authorizations and once the image is
authorized only then you can deploy it
awesome so i just got the signal that
we're running out of time so this is
going to unfortunately be the last
question
and this question comes from wesley
can i use the build integrity features
with my on-prem
software huh okay yeah so um you kind of
can so um with cloud build um it's
really any container image which is
built on
cloud build you can use both on you can
use it in both on-prem or on google
cloud um you just have to use the binary
at binary author test attestation cloud
build
and
it's on it it's on the github page so
you can check that out but if you're
building it with in cloud build um you
can deploy it on prem or
in google cloud
thanks priyanka well that was a lot of
fun it was great to hear all the
questions from the audience you all had
some great ones and i want to say just a
huge thank you to priyanka for joining
us and answering so many of those
questions be sure to join us back over
on g dot co cloud next as the open
infrastructure spotlight will be kicking
off shortly and they have some amazing
things that they're going to show off
thanks for joining us everyone
you